There's a more specific type of binary
tree called a binary search tree.
A binary search tree, or BST,
is definitely a binary tree.
That is, every parent node
has at most two children.
But just as an array is a type of list,
a BST is just a type of binary tree.
There's a specific rule for
how the values associated
with each node are arranged.
BSTs are sorted so every value on
the left of a particular node is smaller
than it and every value on the right
of a particular node is larger than it.
Because BSTs have this structure, we can
do operations like search, insert, and
delete pretty quickly.
Let's say we want to find 7.
We would start at the root.
We see 7 is greater than 5 so
we go right next.
Since our next element is 8,
we know our next move is left.
And in just a few steps we found it.
You may have noticed that we didn't need
to search every element to figure out
where the one I was looking for
belonged.
We just had to look at one value
in each level of the tree, and
then we can make a decision with
just a comparison to my element.
That means the run time of a search on
a BST is just the height of the tree,
which we proved was log(n) when
we learned about inserting.
Inserting in a binary tree is
pretty much the same process.
You start at the top and you can make
quick decisions about where to look at
each step by comparing to
the element you want to add.
Eventually you'll hit that
open spot in the tree.
As long as you compared your
element correctly at each step,
you can put your new element there and
not violate the core BST properties.
Deleting is yet again a bit complicated.
However, it's complicated in the same
way that it was for the generic
binary tree, so those solutions for
different cases still apply.